[Musique]
l'afro guînes est un succès c'est une
catastrophe
on vend beaucoup les gens sont à cran
les blindés une fait de mal je suis
super content qu'une merde dur en pleine
forme je pu faire ça ferrell oui suivant
[Musique]
bienvenue à la première réunion de la
résistance donc on s'appelle pas
tabouret alors rien finalement non ce
que nous voulons c'est que je récupère
mon trop ouais euh non c'est parce qu'on
avait dit on avait dit moins de teint
peau et plus de libertés alors puisque
sinon c'est juste un seigneur qui
remplace un autre
tu te trompes petit singe traîné non là
c'est la démocratie ça à n'avoir c'est
vous qui m'avez du chef
ça y est le roi ils essaient de 30 plus
heureux ah bah oui elle nous fuit le ça
et en plus le premier est gratuit non
mais en même temps c'est pas parce que
c'est gratuit il faut le prendre mais
non c de la b r ça c'est un piège c'est
pas bien ça aurait aimé qu'il paraît que
ça fait oublier les problèmes et non non
j'ai un an
non il faut pas oublier les problèmes
pour résoudre les problèmes
on veut plus de bouffe ou pas mais voilà
les mystères son temps la distance il
décroche tu décroches
oui tout d'abord nous avons encore battu
notre propre record de ventes de frau
guînes applaudissements pour y aurait
elle et son formidable travail
[Applaudissements]
mais justement au vu des effets
secondaires de la drogue de l'afro
guînes je me demandais s'il serait pas
un peu plus sage d'en réduire un tout
petit peu les ventes on va pas faire ça
on est en train de devenir riche irish
entend bien mais je crois que ça rend
les gens un peu maladie est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas au moins utilisé cet argent
pour rendre la vie du peuple un peu plus
agréable ils sont pas heureux là avec
toute la fougue in qu'ils envoient il
doit voir des couleurs incroyables des
farfadets des licornes
je veux parler de l'instauration des
balles pour que les villageoises
rencontrent leurs maris de façon un peu
plus civilisés on en avait parlé des
jarries on en avait parlé mais là si tu
veux on en reparle demain vie en profite
c'est la fait non je veux qu'on en parle
maintenant tu as dit que tu étais
d'accord prêt d'argent va nous servir à
acheter une arme et pas des ballerines
vient pas pissé sur ma part al clarisse
t'es chiant tu veux quoi lafarge veut
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
très bien laisse moi juste un peu de
temps pour m'organiser
je te promets que ton voeu sera exaucé
mais brave si nous voulons récupérer le
pouvoir il faut chasser le seigneur
dragon du trône est ce que vous
connaissez nos points faibles d'un
dragon l'oreille interne
son jeu de jambes non non la tête à tête
faut lui couper la tête
mais ça c'est le point faible de tout le
monde oui mais oui mais non pour que le
corps ces fonds pour lui couper la tête
ça reste un vrai bon moi je suis pas
hyper chaud quand même hein c'est bien
c'est que la masse de planches et un
plan qui ont réuni un maximum de paysans
et de villageois pour former la
révolution on va au château on passe par
un passage secret que seulement et
quelques prostituant connect je me suis
auto balance et c'est pas grave on va
dans le château on complétait du dragon
et on aura plus de goût et lis tu
voulais me voir clarisse je suis content
c'est un grand jour pour toi ah bon tu
m'a souvent dit que tu voulais être
l'égal d'un homme c'est ça oui plus de
différence plus de privilèges errance
parfait c'est exactement ça eh ben
figure toi que j'ai négocié avec ce
monsieur pour qu'il ait plus aucune
différence entre un homme et toi mais en
plus j'ai gagné de l'argent pour en
armer au passage c'est à dire je t ai
vendu quoi 3000 pièces non si c'est pas
possible c'est une blague loi le gala
qu'elle a un peu triste eh ben tu vas
être son égal
pas plus pas moins bon allez moi je dois
y aller
emmenez là à hélices on peut discuter
sont raisonnables non non elle est
l'exemple parfait
j'ai dit 3000 pour pas la vexer mais
j'ai pas pu avoir plus que 1500 était
brut
le mec à nos yeux vous n'êtes pas à
faire cette révolution le prouve en bref
tout près du dragon
des espions
pas de complot
[Musique]